Mein Name ist Mai Thi Nguyen-Kim
und ich bin Chemikerin.
Ich forsche an farbigen Lösungen,
also an knalligen Farben
in Erlenmeyerkolben.
Außerdem erforsche ich
die Wechselwirkungen
zwischen Edding und Glasscheiben.
Und natürlich forsche ich
an Explosionen,
also an Dingen, die explodieren.
Klar, versteht sich ja von selbst.
Ich bin heute hier,
weil ich mich öffentlich
gegen die einseitige
und sehr klischeehafte Darstellung
von Wissenschaftlern
aussprechen möchte.
Wenn man sich Bilder
von Wissenschaftlern anschaut,
dann repräsentieren
die selten die ganze Realität.
Also meistens sind das
alte Männer mit grauen Haaren.
Diese Darstellungen
sind ja auch höchst unattraktiv
für junge Frauen und Mädchen
in unserer heutigen Gesellschaft.
Da fragen sich alle,
ja, wo bleiben denn die Frauen
in den Naturwissenschaften?
Wenn man immer nur alte Männer
mit grauen Haaren sieht,
dann verfestigen
sich solche Klischees wie,
dass Wissenschaftlerinnen
kein Make-up tragen.
Ich trage sehr viel Make-up.
Das sieht man eventuell
manchmal nicht, je nach Explosion.
Das eine schließt ja
das andere nicht aus.
Forschung, Wissenschaft als Ganzes,
aber auch als Beruf
sollte etwas sein, womit sich
viele Menschen identifizieren können.
Und wir als Wissenschaftler
sollten Menschen sein,
Personen sein,
zu denen junge Menschen aufgucken.
Wir sollten Vorbilder sein.
Aber solange wir immer so lächerlich
klischeehaft dargestellt werden,
wird das nicht passieren.
Ich möchte die Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler da draußen
dazu aufrufen, es mir nach zu tun,
in die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen,
sich zu zeigen, damit wir dieses alte
lächerliche Wissenschaftler-Klischee
endlich hinter uns lassen können.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
* Musik *
So'n Mist. Noch mal.